foreign
Ohio and talk to the Great and Powerful
John
what in the world is up John how we
doing
oh man I guess I guess we're doing this
aren't we let's do this man let's do it
what's up brother how are you
uh I'm doing pretty good awesome
I guess a little nervous to be uh to be
talking to you here but I guess we just
uh just get into it huh hey Swan dot no
don't Swan Dive you might hit your head
on the bottom Let's uh Cannonball
cannibal is the great Kevin Dillard says
let's do it
um well I'll I'll start with my question
and then maybe give you some context
okay to put the question around
uh so the question is is how do I
reconcile with my sister
um
I don't reconcile even those really good
word there but the the context of it is
that my uh about a year ago now yeah
probably more than a year ago now
it came out that my sister was carrying
on an affair
um with another married man
um and uh my brother-in-law found out
about it and it ended up they they their
marriage ended in divorce
um recently
and um
Dan I just I lost a lot of respect for
my sister and I've honestly have lost a
lot of respect for my parents through
this whole thing
and I wish it was something that I could
you know just kind of ignore and just
kind of go about my business so you guys
do what you want to do but you know our
family is pretty close and you know we
gotta actually uh family vacation coming
up in uh in a couple of weeks that uh my
brother-in-law who was not invited to
and I guess sides have been drawn to
this whole thing and I feel like I'm you
know pretty firmly behind my
brother-in-law because to me like this
all happened to him he didn't choose for
any of this and it really infuriates me
that
um my parents seem to have taken my
sister's side through all this and
I think that the
um my parents are very very concerned
about maintaining a relationship with
their daughter and with their grandkids
and to me that's like
I don't know I wish my I wish my sister
would show some remorse for what she did
to her family but it doesn't feel like
she is and have you talked to your
sister John have you talked to her
um it's like a private conversation okay
I think all of this is on pause until
you do that
and this is a big enough deal that
[Music]
um
I would get on an airplane and go fly
and sit with her
it says go to coffee
this is a big enough deal where I would
go visit and and at least hear her out
because what you're doing right now is
you are you've heard one side of the
story from brother-in-law yeah
um I can tell you after dealing with
this forever it's never never just one
side there's always another side to it
two
um
ostracization that's probably not the
right I'm not saying that the right way
I'm cutting people off
almost never leads to behavior change
and there's a difference between I love
you
I love you I'm always going to be your
brother
I'm not gonna go on vacation with you
but I'm I I Will Always Love You
and when they say well if you're gonna
love me then you have to do everything
that I say no I don't no I don't
I'm gonna draw some boundaries
but I think you can only do that after
you've done the loving adult grown-up
plus we're brother and sister thing
which is I'm gonna go meet with you in
person so get get like what happened man
and you can you can walk away from those
interactions knowing with a pretty good
sense of what comes next
and it might be Hey sister I I'm not I'm
not comfortable bringing my family
around some strange new guy who's
married to somebody else
uh I'm not comfortable with that
and what you have to balance is
you had this picture of one big happy
family and somebody else blew it up and
you're pissed at them for blowing up
your life which is fair
but be careful that doesn't lead into
you just throwing grenades and rocks at
people because
um you're gonna be throwing grenades and
rocks at them but you're the one that's
going to absorb those explosions
um you can't hold your family like you
can't hold your family together it's
been blown up and so now we have to
create something new does that make
sense
yeah let me let me throw another wrinkle
at you okay
um
she uh my sister
uh only communicates through written
and that's kind of something that has
made me angry because I guess I'll have
a piece of it because like
you know she she communicates everything
through email Facebook posts or text
messages
and that's something that you know I'm
like if you want to talk to me come talk
to me
um or something you want to say talk to
me like I don't I can't do this whole
email except except you're the one with
the problem
yeah so it needs to go the other way
I I think you're 100 right I would not
communicate to somebody electronically
like that
I wouldn't do that and so if somebody
says this is my new boundary
um I will only talk via Facebook and
text message that's a new bit that's a
new thing that's come out in the last
few years by the way these strange
family boundaries like I only feel safe
texting okay that's fine but when you
say that you are opting out a
relationship with me at this time
because I only talk in person to the
people I love of course I send funny
text messages back and forth my sister
texted me last night because the Astros
got Verlander back that's all great but
when it comes to substantive things we
talk on the phone we go we talk in
person
we don't do long I don't do in fact one
of my mentors uh Michael Sean rock man
one of the awesomest guys in the world
um he always had like a piece of tape on
his on his computer and if the email was
too long he just he would wouldn't even
read it he would just reply like hey set
up a meeting
like I must I'm not gonna do all of this
in email I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
do it in a person and so I think it's
fair to say if she chooses that I think
it's fair to text her back and say I
want to come visit you and talk with you
and take you to coffee would you meet
with me and if she says I only am going
to do this via Facebook or whatever you
can write her back and say this is too
big of a deal to continue this exchange
when you're ready to talk in person I
can't wait and I'll be there
and let that be the end of it
because she's drawn this weird boundary
and you've gotten pissed that she drew a
boundary
that's fine I wouldn't spend one second
energy being upset with her I would just
draw my own boundary back
is it like so and I hope you hear me say
this and I'm not trying to be dismissive
I understand how bad this hurts it
messes up everything
um
but also I I just wouldn't give all this
energy in angst into energy and angst
like I want to hear what you have to say
and if you don't want to talk to me then
you're opting out of relationship with
me that breaks my heart makes me sad it
kind of confirms what I was thinking
anyway about your character but man
you're going through some stuff cool
hey Mom and Dad everybody we're gonna on
my family we're gonna opt out of the
family vacation this year I appreciate
you guys it's just it's everything's
pretty hot
um sister doesn't even want to talk in
person I'm we're gonna opt out we're
gonna do our own thing this year we love
you guys and we look forward to getting
back together next year
that's that
yeah that'd be some
I guess sacrifice one of the reason why
I was kind of swallowing my pride or
whatever is just going along with it go
to the family vacations because
I've got two kids and my kids and her
kids really only see each other once a
year at these Vacations so I've always
kind of buddy let's go because the
cousins need to have a relationship with
Charlie at least in my opinion I 100
agree but if she's opting out of
relationship with you guys there's not a
lot you can do
yeah that's true because you end up
compromising your value so yes in a
perfect world
cousins are all Linked UP
it's the way it should be
but if somebody opts out of that
relationship
if somebody's not trustworthy if
somebody doesn't tell the truth if
somebody will only connect via what like
I can't I can't I'm not going to
compromise my values and the values of
my family to prop up this picture of
what I want to be true
um it's just it's just it's
heartbreaking
and it's really hard in the fog I mean
the smoke of of of a raging fire to
understand that it will burn out
so this one summer that you might have
to miss on the family vacation
the cousins will get together
this isn't going to be a forever thing
it'll get together they'll have tons of
fun it'll be a blast
they will get together maybe not maybe
not this year that's fine
but let's don't let's don't burn
everything to the ground trying to prop
up a picture that's been burned down
picture's gone man
things are going to be different
and my hope is let's let the adults
um
let's let the adults be adults and let's
dig into this thing and figure it out
together
I'm proud of you man I hate this for you
I hate this for you but let's get on the
phone and it's worth it's worth the
Southwest flight man
um if you if you don't live in the same
neighborhood if you live in the same
neighborhood dude I'd try to get
together tonight but it's worth the
flight to sit down with your sister face
to face and say hey I miss you are you
okay what happened
and she tells you nah I just cheated on
my husband with a married dude
YOLO One Life to Live whatever you can
say hey that's that's just
I love you you're my sister that's not
something I'm going to be a part of
I can't be a part of that I don't want
my kids around that and I want more for
you and I love my brother-in-law so he's
gonna stay my friend
and um if you choose to walk away that
you can choose to do that and then you
can make those boundary judgments right
but let's let's don't throw rocks until
we've had a chance to sit at a table
with somebody
and by the way that goes for all of us
I'm talking to myself here this is me
talking to the man in the mirror
um
let's have a conversation first before
we throw any rocks